dieser neu entdeckte planet stellt die
wissenschaft vor große rätsel denn es
handelt sich um ein echtes riesenbaby
und das in verblüffender nähe zu erde
und nicht nur seine entstehung ist bei
den fachleuten bisher unerklärlich
klicks um science-fiction da gibt es
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
der neue aufgespürte planet heißt thomas
11 55 79 19
und es handelt sich um ein echtes
riesenbaby laut dem us forschungsteam
dem die verblüffende entdeckung mit
hilfe des weltraumteleskops gelang hat
der planet die zehnfache masse des
jupiter und das ist alles andere als
wenig denn dieser gas riese gilt als der
größte planet im sonnensystem zudem
befindet sich der riesenbaby planet
zumindest in kosmischen dimensionen in
unserer direkten nachbarschaft mit einer
entfernung von nur 330 lichtjahren
handelt es sich somit nach angaben der
fachleute um ein objekt das zitat näher
an der erde liegt als jeder andere
ähnlich junge planet der bisher gefunden
wurde die neuen analysen zufolge umkreis
der gigantisch große baby planet einen
stern der fünf millionen jahre alt ist
und damit 1000 mal jünger als unsere
sonne
dabei befindet sich toom es 115 5 7 919
in einer extrem großen distanz zu seinen
stern nach angaben der fachleute ist die
entfernung etwa 60 mal so groß wie die
zwischen erde und sonne warum und wie
der riesige baby planet in seine
position gelangt ist für
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit ein großes rätsel dazu die
astrophysikerin any dixon wander felde
die an der aktuellen studie beteiligt
war das objekt das wir gefunden haben
ist sehr jung und dabei zehn mal so groß
wie jupiter
was bedeutet dass wir wahrscheinlich
einen baby planeten betrachten der sich
vielleicht noch mitten in seiner
entstehung befindet obwohl durch die
kepler mission und ähnliche mission
viele andere planeten entdeckt wurden
handelt es sich bei fast allen um alte
planeten
doch hierbei handelt es sich um das
vierte oder fünfte beispiel eines
riesigen planeten der so weit von seinem
mutter stern entfernt ist theoretiker
haben große mühe zu erklären wie es dazu
gekommen ist möglichst bald sollen unter
anderem spektroskopische analyse
folgen um mehr über das mysteriöse
objekt und seine entstehung zu erfahren
der erste exoplanet mit wasser leben auf
caa2 18b möglich anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren und zwar kicks und science
fiction ein besonderer dank geht an
dieser stelle an alle unterstützerinnen
und unterstützer ihr seid super und
danke für eure kanal mit schafft bis
dann bleibt dran